[Musique]
voir les enfants
j'espère que vous êtes tous de bonne
humeur et que vous ne gagnez pas
comme nounours
que faut-il faire quand quelqu'un grogne
mon petit doigt me dit qu'il faut le
gronder hongre alors nounours je vais te
gronder très fort car ce soir tu n'es
pas de bonne humeur nos patrons ne me
gronder pas j'ai des soucis plein de
soucis donc
[Musique]
je suis à nounours
incompris et bien descend vite voir tes
amis ou les
poteaux propose
ce qu'il est gâté nous
[Musique]
regarde
j'ai pensé à vous chers amis oui c'est
dada qui a porté tout ça poutre du tabac
une pipe aux tâches heures data que vous
êtes chaud je vous ai fait plaisir rouge
c'est exactement ce qu'il me faut ce
soir du bon tabac
j'ai du bon tabac dans la tabatière que
j'ai du bon tabac et dans le rap à
mantet du phare et du bien rater mais ce
n'est pas tout empêcher j'ai du bon
tabac dans ma tabatière j'ai du bon
tabac mais non au rap
[Musique]
j'ai du bon tabac pour bourrer petit
j'ai du bon tabac mais non n'aura pas
j'en ai du blond et noir et du riz je
lui en donne tout cas mes actes j'ai du
bon tabac pourrait pas tout
j'ai du bon tabac et non au rap
[Musique]
oh je me sens bien je suis réconforté
j'emporte ma pipe et mon tabac au revoir
a mis
au revoir tata et vous les enfants au
luxe
et nous nous
la nuit vous apporte à tous calme et
tranquillité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dû beau papa un notre nounours ne
grogne plus long mon cher patron avec
une pipe et du bon tabac j'ai tout ce
qu'il me faut pour être heureux
tp - dole tout pas trop allons
là
s'est passé oui route
bonnut les enfants allaient sagement
vous coucher le feu de boer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or